oh my God the celebrity and or artist  and or YouTuber and or stand-up  comedians getting canceled this person  is off I could always tell what yeah I  knew this would happen you knew about  all of this I just had a bad feeling  about him you know bad vibes anyways the  the victims are speaking out about it I  never even liked him in the first place  so so I was right can I get some credit  for that or you knew he was a creep I  knew he was a hack and on funny so same  thing no his show sucked yeah I didn't  love it either why do you look so happy  I'm not maybe this should be about the  victims right and not you God I'm so  glad I didn't consume his content back  then because I can be self-righteous now  stop I'm better than you